you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
transforming scotland's energy sector
the largest ever auction of offshore
wind farm permits gives the go-ahead for
17 new
projects from flooding to farming a
government assessment of climate risks
says multiple sectors of the uk will be
affected by even low rises in global
temperatures
lords debate the policing bill which
activists say would curb their right to
peaceful protests at a critical time in
the fight against climate change
and scientists arrive in antarctica to
assess the impact of climate change on
penguin colonies
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now wind farm contracts worth
700 million pounds have been awarded to
energy companies to develop offshore
schemes along scotland's coast on what
the first minister described as one of
the biggest most significant days for
the nation's energy and industrial
future in the country's largest ever
auction of permits to develop the
scottish seabed companies including
shell bp and scottish power will provide
low carbon power while helping to cut
emissions to net zero
so to begin with almost 7 000 square
kilometers of seabed will be leased for
17 different projects now this will
generate close to 25 000 megawatts of
power
that's enough to power 18 million 750
000 homes
scottish first minister nicolas sturgeon
spoke to our business presenter ian king
about that announcement earlier today
i mean it's really hard to overstate how
significant and important today's
announcement is for scotland's energy
environmental and economic future i mean
this gives us the potential to meet our
own energy needs from renewable sources
it's going to position scotland as a
major exporter of green energy green
hydrogen as well and delivers massive
economic benefits as well as the
revenues that will flow to the scottish
government the estimate is that for
every gigawatt of power generated from
these projects in due course there'll be
a billion pounds of investment in the
supply chain and that has the potential
to create thousands perhaps tens of
thousands of jobs so as we make this
transition to net zero to meet the
climate emergency this helps ensure
scotland can do that in a fair and
adjust way that creates new jobs to
replace those in oil and gas for example
which we are in the process of
transitioning away from this is perhaps
one of the biggest most significant days
in terms of scotland's energy and
industrial future that we've had in a
very very long time really exciting i
mean the impact on our marine
environment including fishing
opportunities is one of the things that
we'll have to be carefully considered
now as we move from today's
announcements through the planning and
consenting processes so there's a lot of
work ahead i mean our sectoral marine
plan envisaged about 10 gigawatts of
energy from offshore
wind developments at the sum total of
today's projects that have been given at
these leased options it would be perhaps
25 gigawatts so significantly in excess
of that current planning assumption now
we want to maximize our opportunities
here but of course you're right to say
there are other users of scotland's
precious marine environment so making
sure that all of this aligns will be one
of the key challenges over the period
ahead but you know that challenge has to
be seen in the context of the massive
energy environmental and economic
opportunity that this represents for us
now you touched just now on the
decarbonisation of scotland's energy
industry i just wonder why you're so
opposed to the development of the cambo
oil field in west shetland given that
it's surely more desirable for us to be
having our own energy sources rather
than buying it in from people like
vladimir putin
well i i don't favor anything that makes
us more reliant on imports and i
certainly don't favor anything that you
know would compromise people's jobs and
livelihoods but we face a climate
emergency you know i'm here in irvine
the town i grew up in as it happens not
far from glasgow that just
a matter of weeks ago hosted cop26 we
all have an obligation a moral
obligation to face up to the climate
emergency and for scotland the uk
countries across the world that means
transitioning away from fossil fuels but
we need to do that in a way that
protects jobs that protects livelihoods
that doesn't increase our reliance on
imports so that's a careful
journey that we have to undertake but
scotland as today's announcement is
really uh illustrating foreign is in the
happy fortunate position of not just
having had oil and gas resources for
several decades now but also having this
abundance of renewable energy resources
well our business correspondent paul
kelso joins me now so paul in the last
month around a quarter of our energy
supplies come from wind so how much
difference will these contracts make
in the long term they'll make a very big
difference and no wonder the first
minister was so excited about this so
she's right this is a huge
commitment to renewable particularly
wind specifically wind power in scotland
who's going to net her government
ultimately 700 million pounds this
auction by the crown estate scotland who
own the seabed so they've leased uh this
seabed for this use the big uh
technological shift here which the first
minister didn't mention is the bulk of
these projects are floating wind farms
for the first time the majority almost
all of the wind power that's already
generating if you say a quarter around a
quarter of you the uk's energy
electricity supplies at the moment is
fixed and there's a limit ultimately to
the engineering to how far off offshore
you can go once once you are as long as
you are still tethered to the ocean bed
about 165 feet uh deep about 30 40
meters is the limit at the moment now
floating offshore wind opens up much
greater distances offshore where the
wind speeds are much much higher and the
north sea is a savage place extremely
high wind the more wind the more power
you can generate so that's where the
real dividend from this new technology
will be i spoke to keith anderson the
chief executive of scottish power which
has won three of these sites it will do
two of them in a joint partnership which
shell of course who have experience in
the north sea's last great energy boom
which was oil and he said there is uh he
described this almost as a no-lose
project
so this is great for several reasons
number one
it moves us away from volatile wholesale
markets and gas prices
number two
it delivers us closer and closer to net
zero by 2050 and number three it
produces a fixed price for power at some
of the lowest prices possible in the
entire market so renewable energy is
cheaper and it's the cheapest form of
generation in the united kingdom
now this will take time to deliver work
will start on these floating offshore
wind farms in the late uh at the end of
this decade and could take up to another
decade to be completed but it's crucial
if the uk is to transition fully to
renewables and away from the source of
this current anxiety about massively
spiking energy prices which is the
reliance on gas to bridge this gap
between the decline of coal because of
its carbon emissions and a renewable
future but the north sea once the source
of all that oil could soon be the source
of wind power which could power not just
the uk
but much of europe
paul thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look now some of the
day's other climate news and huge brands
including coca-cola and nestle are
calling for an end to plastic pollution
the businesses have signed an open
letter recommending a legally binding
plastic treaty ahead of the un's
environment assembly conference taking
place next month in practice the treaty
could end the leakage of plastics into
marine environments within a decade
the house of lords has been debating the
police crime sentencing and courts bill
which has sparked kill the bill protests
across the country campaigners have
argued that without any changes the
legislation would curb the right to
peaceful protest
climate activist groups have said the
bill will undermine the fight against
climate change at a critical point and
we'll be discussing this with author and
presenter zia tong and lecturer in
climate law at edinburgh university
navraj singh gali that's later in the
programme
now the government's latest assessment
on the risk from climate change
identifies dozens of issues facing the
uk
even if global warming is successfully
limited in the decades ahead now if
temperatures rise by two degrees by the
year 2100 the country could see farming
water supply and alternative energy
supplies affected as well as more
flooding and a greater impact on public
health now it's estimated that this will
cost the uk billions of pounds each year
and some experts are warning that
temperatures could rise even higher by
the end of the century by as much as
four degrees so let's take a look now at
the current increase in global
temperatures and as you can see there
it's now around 1.24 degrees above
pre-industrial levels
well joining me now is the chair in
climate impacts at the university of
exeter professor richard best who led
the research that forms the basis of
today's report welcome to you first of
all has the government accepted in full
your assessment
of the risks facing the country as a
result of climate change
yes they've taken on board our advice
they've looked through all our very
comprehensive assessment of these 61
risks and they've completely accepted
that these risks exist and need to be
dealt with with great urgency so we
welcome this report which now recognizes
the urgency of the situation so just how
prepared are we as a country
not at all unfortunately um we've gone
through all the different risks which uh
in actual fact many of them are starting
to come into play now we've already
changed the climate as you just showed
we've warmed the world by over a degree
celsius
that is starting to play out in terms of
impacts on severe weather we're getting
more severe heat waves more heavy
rainfall which affects the flooding risk
and so on these are having an impact
already uh and more climate change is in
the pipeline unless we can reduce
emissions but even if we reduce
emissions enough to meet the ambitious
decarbonisation targets we'll see more
warming and more severe weather and
further sea level rise
and the government has admitted hasn't
it that it needs to do more so what do
you think the priority should be now
so there's a number of priorities one is
clearly dealing with higher temperatures
all buildings basically need to be able
to
keep cool in summer uh we're not used to
that so much in in the uk so private
residential properties we hear a lot
about the need for insulation uh to make
them more energy efficient and keep them
warm in winter which is very important
but that would also help keep buildings
cool in summer so that's another
reason to insulate private homes uh but
also
other properties schools hospitals
prisons and so on everything needs to be
able to deal with high temperatures but
also flooding we need greater protection
against flooding as well we're seeing
more heavy rainfall and flooding is
already having an impact increasingly
often so we need to do more there as
well
lots to do professor richard betts
thanks very much indeed for your time
today
thank you
now to the antarctic peninsula now where
researchers have arrived to study remote
penguin colonies researchers travelled
to the antarctic peninsula on a
greenpeace ship called the arctic
sunrise scientists will be assessing the
climate crisis impacts on penguin
colonies after other groups in the area
have collapsed over the past 50 years
their arrival is in time for penguin
awareness day on thursday which aims to
raise awareness for the conservation of
the species habitat
now do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by
author and presenter zayatong and
lecturer in climate law at edinburgh
university navraj singh gali and we're
going to be discussing the policing bill
and its effect on the climate protest
movement and is the global political and
diplomatic system equipped to deal with
the challenge of climate change
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
author and presenter zia tong and
lecturer in climate law at edinburgh
university navraj singh gali so very
good evening to both of you nice to see
you both
so first of all the policing bill is
being debated in the house of lords
today and it's provoked much debate and
indeed protest the government stands
accused of wanting to stifle peaceful
protests with the legislation which was
proposed in part at least in reaction to
insulate britain protesters disrupting
commuters last year so is this kind of
legislation really a threat to peaceful
protests
and how important is the role of protest
in the climate context anyway
navrati to you first of all what impact
do you think this policing bill could
have on future protests and on the
broader climate movement
thank you um so this is a pretty uh
intrusive piece of legislation that i
think has been
fairly poorly drafted and um certainly
hasn't had the opportunity for proper
scrutiny
one of the risks of it is it's
huge breadth the bill doesn't just deal
with climate or environmental protesters
deals with matters such as road traffic
offenses sexual violence accessing
information on electronic devices so
it's a massive bill hundreds and
hundreds of pages long and what one
thing that that means is that it's
very difficult to scrutinize
um and the constitution committee if the
house of lords made exactly this point
um has made the point before but the
government ignored that
advice so procedurally
it's a bit of a dog's dinner um
substantively there are some really
challenging
uh uh issues uh or approaches that the
bill has taken i think the first of
these is that it
has this um you know we're in the realm
of public order here and peaceful
protest um and it has this idea of a
noise trigger so noise triggers can if
there's an uh that can be a condition
uh which uh police officers
uh can impose on a peaceful protest if
the if there's a noise trigger we know
that protests are often noisy people
bang drums or their fpa systems and so
on um and the idea that that can be the
basis for
restricting a protest i think is very
troubling and it's very likely that that
will contravene
either the european convention of human
rights
or the common law and most likely both
i just want to get some reaction from
zaya as well
sorry to interrupt there but um as i
we've got a real sense there haven't we
of some of navraj's concerns about it
but those who are behind this bill might
say well yeah we want people to protest
but disrupting the lives of people going
about their their everyday
lives shouldn't necessarily be allowed
and their this bill would tougher
sentences for blocking motorways or
other forms of transport for example
there are going to be people that will
support that aren't there
well there might be but i think we have
to look with a historical lens and we
have to realize that what we see as a
nuisance today is often seen through the
lens of history is something quite
monumental for progressive change so if
i think of the suffragettes who were
you know tying themselves and chaining
themselves to buildings and blocking
traffic i say thank you because of you i
as a woman have the right to vote today
if i think of the hay market protesters
who created a huge nuisance thank you
because of you i only work eight hours a
day instead of twelve if i look at for
example the clay quit sound protesters
who chained themselves to trees and
created a huge nuisance for the logging
industry thank you today we have old
growth forests but even if you look from
a geographic lens when we look overseas
and we see for example regimes we look
at say you know russia or china or the
middle east and we say they're quashing
descent and they're stopping their
protesters and we say that's
totalitarian well if it's totalitarian
overseas it's totalitarian as home at
home as well
navraj very quickly though i mean
do they actually make a difference
whether protests are peaceful or
disruptive i mean they may make people
talk about them but certainly if they're
stopping people going around their their
daily lives it can
it can put people off the argument can't
it very briefly if you can
for the avoidance of doubt we're only
talking about the realm of peaceful
protest there's nothing about disorder
here um
this is how issues get ventilated as you
just heard from the other guests issues
get ventilated in ways which are
sometimes inconvenient and inconvenience
as a central part of peaceful protest
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we um to try and squeeze another
conversation in because the government's
admitted that it's not doing enough to
adapt to the impacts of climate change
that's in response to a report from the
climate change committee now the
government was also recently accused of
a lack of effective policy when it comes
to reaching net zero targets so can we
rely on governments to do the right
thing not just here but also
internationally is the global diplomatic
system equipped to tackle the climate
crisis so xia what do you think can
governments be relied on and if not
what's the alternative
well i think that uh the incremental
system change approach is certainly not
working if we look at almost 30 years of
cops we're seeing a situation that is a
much greater crisis today than when they
started the same thing even if you're
looking at the united nations
declaration on the rights for indigenous
people there was legislation passed in
bc where i'm from and still today we're
not seeing accountability we're not
seeing meaningful change we're seeing
land offenders and water defenders being
arrested by the rcmp the police we're
seeing pipelines being built on unseated
territory we're seeing forests being
raised so we need to start thinking
about a different type of system change
and you know we always think oh system
change is that even possible and we
forget colonialism fairly recent was a
form of system change you had europeans
sweeping across the rest of the world
exporting a model an idea that nature
was inert and an object that you could
go in there and you could destroy
exploit extract and bring it to market
and that is the system that has brought
us the crisis the climate crisis and the
extinction crisis that we face today so
we need to learn from a more reciprocal
model that we've seen from indigenous
people so system change really starts
with changing how we think about the
system okay enough do accept those
arguments let's let's deal with cop in
particular
zaya saying that it's not effective do
you think that's right because some
might say that the last cop did see the
big polluters coming on board with at
least some new commitments and a
commitment as well to come back later
this year to be held to account do you
agree with zaya or do you agree with
those people who stand up for that form
of diplomacy
cop has a role and
its role is to set a set of broad
standards
and processes which can which have to
address the climate crisis in a number
of different ways
but it can't do everything and the real
and i think um the cop process through
the paris agreement which is flawed in a
number of different ways nonetheless
sets some of those standards where the
real deficit is coming as a national
action and sub-national action corporate
action that's where we're really not
seeing the follow-through so if you look
at um something called the climate
action tracker which has a rating system
of national actions
practically no northern uh states which
is what we're principally talking about
have a standard of action which is
regarded as almost
sufficient or
uh paris compatible none do in fact the
united kingdom is the only country which
is almost sufficient most of the rest of
the global north is highly insufficient
so that's really where we need to see
the action
at that level and corporates need to
follow
you know what all that was said about
system change i entirely agree with
there's no question that there is in
order to meet any form of meaningful
climate action there is a need of system
change which means a lot more than
driving a electric car and
eating less meat it's fundamental
changes to the way we produce and
consume in exchange okay and there's
several hours worth of debate to discuss
how that will work which we don't have
time for right now of course now fresh
singh zayatong always good to hear your
views thanks both very much indeed for
joining us tonight
well tomorrow i'll be joined by the
director of policy and translation at
the grantham institute alyssa gilbert
and professor of global change science
at university college london and the
university of leeds simon lewis but for
now thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you